un petit pas pour l'homme un bond de
géant pour l'humanité en prononçant
cette phrase il ya quarante ans jour
pour jour neil amstrong venait d'entrer
dans l'histoire madame monsieur bonsoir
bienvenue au 20h nous reviendrons bien
sûr longuement dans ce journal sur cet
anniversaire des premiers pas de l'homme
sur la lune avec notamment le témoignage
de l'astronaute française claudie
haigneré
elle avait 12 ans à l'époque mais elle
se souvient très bien de cette nuit du
20 juillet 69
elle est avec nous ce soir nous
parlerons aussi des dangers de la mer
sur l'océan atlantique un groupe d'une
dizaine d'adolescents emportés par les
courants de marée ont évité le pire hier
soir dans les landes
et ce matin encore devant notre caméra
cinq personnes ont échappé de justesse à
la noyade le reportage exclusif dans ce
journal
la grippe a ne présente pas seulement
des risques pour la santé mais aussi
pour l'économie
certains experts estiment que l'épidémie
pourrait reporter la reprise d'une voire
deux années après les fils de cuivre les
voleurs s'intéresse désormais aux
panneaux solaires le phénomène est
encore marginale mais il s'étend dans
toute l'europe avec ce qui ressemble
vous le verrez à une filière organisée
enfin nous nous rendrons sur les pentes
du mont ventoux alors que les pros du
tour de france se reposait aujourd'hui
les accros eux ont enfourché leur vélo
plus de 9000 cycliste du monde entier
amateurs pour la plupart sont partis à
l'assaut du célèbre roman provençal
on commence avec les salariés de new
fabris à châtellerault qui ont
finalement décidé aujourd'hui de
suspendre leur menace de faire sauter
leur usine en signe de bonne volonté ils
ont enlevé les bonbonnes de gaz qu'ils
avaient installées sur place françois
privat jeudi à de l'âge ils abattent
leur ultime carte
les ex salariés de fabris suspens de la
menace de faire exploser leur usine le
31 juillet prochain
en échange d'un rendez vous mercredi
avec le ministre de l'industrie
christian estrosi
l'idée du sud au rabais
en août la haute montée là où il fait
quoi
quelques minutes plus tôt lourd climat
lors de l'assemblée générale on ne
laisse rien tombé aujourd'hui on a fait
un jeu si on nous a demandé un geste
fait un geste on attend que monsieur
estrosi fasse le sien il se soit
constructif on montre qu'on est
intelligent et on n'est pas des voyous
tout simplement voilà en fin de semaine
dernière des hommes des femmes
désemparées
quand peugeot et renault principaux
clients de fabrice refusent d'octroyer à
chacun d'eux une prime exceptionnelle de
30000 euros
singer le désarroi ans si tu ne sais
plus quoi faire
on se venge
malgré nous cesser il met désormais tous
leurs espoirs dans le rendez vous de
mercredi avec une conviction affichée ne
pas repartir les mains vides
en cas d'échec il réinstalleront les
bouteilles de gaz
cinq jours après le premier cas de
grippe a dans une colonie de vacances du
pas-de-calais le bilan s'est alourdi on
compte désormais 34 personnes
contaminées dont une vingtaine d'enfants
seuls trois adultes ont dû être
hospitalisés à titre de précaution une
des animatrices et toujours ce soir sous
surveillance alors je vous le disais
dans les titres ce fameux virus a h1n1
inquiète pas seulement les autorités de
santé il inquiète aussi désormais les
économistes plusieurs experts estiment
que l'épidémie pourrait gripper sans jeu
de mots le système est retardé la
reprise économique d'une année ou deux
quoi qu'il en soit dans les entreprises
françaises on se prépare voyez cet
exemple à lille fabien shadow réunion de
crise dans cette entreprise lilloise
la patronne et ses cadres se préparait
une éventuelle épidémie qu'on s'a tour
et aliou condé n'a pas commis ces
dernières années plusieurs pour les
salariés cinq mille masques ont été
commandés du télétravail est aussi
prévue mais dans cette grosse pme
on se prépare surtout à une baisse
d'activité car ici on fabrique des
drapeaux idée tribune pour des
événements sportifs
si les manifestations publiques sont
interdites la production pourrait chuter
de 80% pour contourner l'épidémie pas
question de compter sur les usines à
l'étranger
on a une main d'oeuvre ici qu'à une
grosse valeur ajoutée peut pas se
permettre du jour au lendemain d'aller
là les délocaliser sa dans les pays qui
de toute façon eux-mêmes auront le même
type de problème avec leur propre
personnel et si jamais demain on a
fermeture des frontières on peut plus
entrer pu fournir dans ses prévisions
les plus pessimistes l'entreprise serait
incapable d'importer les matières
premières et d'exporter voilà comment la
grippe a pourrait contaminer l'économie
mondiale
on en vient maintenant aux dangers de la
mer il est important de le rappeler en
cette période de vacances il ya des
règles à respecter
la première sur l'atlantique lorsqu'un
courant de marée vous emporte qu'il ne
faut pas résisté ce réflexe a d'ailleurs
probablement sauvé la vie hier soir à
une douzaine d'adolescents dans les
landes et ce matin encore un drame a été
évité devant notre caméra
le reportage est signée valérie le rouge
et zidane berkous peu de répit pour les
sauveteurs des plages landaises 10h30 ce
matin la baignade n'est pas encore
officiellement surveiller 5 baigneurs se
font entraîné au large
impossible pour eux de revenir sans
l'aide des maîtres nageurs une
intervention simple et rapide cette fois
pour les sauveteurs mais hier ils sont
passés près du drame
onze jeunes britanniques un français se
font surprendre par un courant violent à
l'extrémité de la zone de baignade
autorisée dans quelques secondes
pris de panique il ya eu plusieurs
boîtes ils sont enlevés en même temps
j'avais que deux sauveteurs dans le
groupe je renvoyais du monde
le courant les attirer très loin j'ai
suggéré de faire appel à l'hélicoptère
six rotations d'hélicoptère plus tard et
tous les nageurs sont sains et saufs
cet après midi quelques uns étaient de
retour à la plage
difficile d'oublier leur mésaventure
en fait on n'a pas réalisé s'est rendu
compte qu'on était trop loin quand on
s'est retourné s'est dit qu'il fallait
qu'on regagne la plage mais on n'a pas
plus ce sont les baïnes ces cuves est
visible à marée basse qui provoque des
courants violents à marée haute
impossible alors de les repérer excepté
par un léger frémissement de l'eau en
cas d' aspiration vers le large de
consignes à suivre surtout ne pas
s'épuiser à ramer et puis surtout
prévenir les sauveteurs après dans les
meilleures conditions et pour pouvoir
être repérés par les sauveteurs il faut
bien rester dans les zones surveillées
même si c'est un peu frustrant devant
l'immensité de l'océan
l'ump a finalement remporté la bataille
d'aix-en-provence d'une courte tête
maryse joissains a été réélue à la
mairie avec 187 voix d'avancé face à la
coalition ps modem écologistes emmenée
par alexandre medvedowsky
ce dernier a déclaré qu'il comptait
déposer un recours devant le tribunal
administratif il souhaite notamment
faire vérifier les votes par procuration
autre passe d'armes en vue entre
l'opposition et l'ump elle aura lieu
demain avec le retour du fameux texte
hadopi à l'assemblée nationale en ce
moment même le ministre de la culture
frédéric mitterrand reçoit une
délégation socialiste qui souhaite
ajourné la présentation de ce texte un
texte qui pose de nombreux problèmes
politiques mais aussi juridique
il concerne vous le savez la
réglementation des droits d'auteur sur
internet
mais la loi a tellement été amendée
qu'il est difficile aujourd'hui de s'y
retrouver
où en est-on exactement que risque un
internaute qui pratiquent le
téléchargement illégal
voici avec daniel wolfromm aujourd'hui
on ne risque pratiquement rien à
télécharger sur internet
aucune loi spécifique ne vient
sanctionner cette pratique toutefois
copier un nombre considérable de films
ou de musique pour les revendre et puni
par la loi
c'est un délit de contrefaçon mais il
est rarement utilisée pour l'internet
maintenant si la loi hadopi du nom de la
haute autorité qui l'encadrent était
adopté ces jours ci voilà ce qui
pourrait advenir dans un premier temps
l'autorité administrative mais traite en
garde le pirate par un mail
d'avertissement
puis en cas de récidive lui enverrait
une lettre recommandée
mais si la fraude se poursuit dans un
deuxième temps cette même autorité
pourrait transmettre à la justice le
dossier du pirate dans le meilleur des
cas il pourrait avoir une amende pour
négligence caractérisée
jusqu'à 1500 euros assortie ou pas d'une
coupure d'un mois de son internet
mais pour les contrefaçons les plus
graves la suppression de l'abonnement
pourrait aller jusqu'à un an l'amande
atteindre 300 mille euros et le pirate
encourir jusqu'à un an d'emprisonnement
ils sont presque devenus des demi-dieux
aux etats unis 40 ans après avoir marché
sur la lune neil armstrong michael
collins et buzz aldrin s'apprête à être
reçu à la maison blanche tout le pays
est derrière ces héros pour fêter cet
anniversaire planétaire sur place alain
de chalvron adriana sanchez pour ce 40e
anniversaire la nasa a réussi l'exploit
de faire sortir de sa tanière neil
amstrong l'homme du premier pas qui fuit
d'ordinaire micros et caméras trop
émotif peut-être merci à tous pour nous
avoir permis de célébrer l'anniversaire
de ce vol dans l'espace
et pour l'occasion la gent spatial nous
a offert ces images extraordinaires qui
avaient été effacées c'est à peine
croyable est récupéré par miracle puis
restauré par des spécialistes
d'hollywood
on y voit les deux astronautes déployé
le drapeau américain sur l'astre lunaire
un beau cadeau pour le grand public il y
avait buzz aldrin le deuxième lunaire
lui qui adore au contraire micros et
caméras prêt à signer son dernier livre
au musée de l'air et de l'espace de
washington
aldrin l'inlassable avocats de la
poursuite de l' aventure spatiale
je pense qu'il faut revenir à ce que la
nasa et ce pays ont vraiment envie de
voir
c'est à dire l'exploration est bon à
l'exploration c'est allé là on n'est
jamais allé avant car ce 40e
anniversaire en suscitant la nostalgie
provoque aussi le rêve
et à washington aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup de mars la planète rouge
well and savons que l'on retrouve en
direct de washington bonsoir alain on
vient de voir armstrong si discret
depuis 40 ans est sorti de sa tanière il
a même accepté l'invitation de barack
obama ce soir c'est dire si l'événement
est important aux états unis oui
évidemment vous savez ça rappelle de
bons souvenirs un des sommets de la
puissance américaine est en fait en ces
temps de crise ça fait pas de mal de
revivre tout ça alors les médias ne s'en
prive pas et barack obama ne s'en
privera pas non plus vous savez
l'amérique a besoin de ce que kennedy
appelait ses nouvelles frontières alors
c'était la conquête de l'ouest c'était
la conquête spatiale et aujourd'hui est
bien le manque peut-être d'un objectif
comme ça qui fait rêver alors y'a pas
que l'espace naturellement mais la nasa
espère qu'il y aura aussi l'espace car
son futur et disons un certain encore
sept tirs de navettes et puis un bac pro
j'ai appelé constellation mais surtout
beaucoup de coupes budgétaires et de
licenciement alors barack obama ne s'est
pas encore prononcé là dessus la
politique spatiale fait l'objet d'une
remise à plat de l'administration mais
pas de doute que cette rencontre avec
les trois astronautes d'apollo 11
nourrir à sa réflexion
merci alain alors on fait ce soir les 40
ans d'apollon justement celle des
premiers pas sur la lune mais il y en a
eu d'autres par la suite le programme
apollo a duré jusqu'en 72 et en tout
douze astronautes ont foulé le sol
lunaire
voici le concentré des plus belles
images de toute leur mission
patrice pollet jean-jacques le garrec le
16 juillet 69 armstrong collins et
aldrin se dirige vers la lune objectif
se poser hanachi la décision politique
de kennedy épaulé par un budget
gigantesque est entré à paul 11 dans la
légende
au moment où l'homme l'être humain qui
représente notre espèce marche sur la
lune et les décrit la poussière qui
décolle à chaque pas et qu'il se sent
léger
là c'est vraiment très fort
anecdote
armstrong a failli ne jamais foulé le
sol lunaire quelques mois plus tôt à
l'entraînement et ne panne sur le lem
l'obligent à s'éjecter
armstrong
alvin l'histoire parfois cruel ne
retiendra que c'est de nous pourtant
derrière eux
dix astronautes au cours de cinq
missions ont accompli la même prouesse
après 12 et 14 ils se sont posés ils ont
juste marcher un peu autour ramasser des
cailloux opposé des instruments
scientifiques est rentré au bout de
quelques heures ou en fait assez
rapidement entre 12 et 14 il y le
chiffre porte malheur le xiii de la
mission apollo 13 et bien une
catastrophe
le réservoir d'hydrogène liquide explose
juste après le décollage
lowell swinger t.aez iront jusqu à
bricoler un purificateur d'air
il échappe à la mort mais il ne
marcheront jamais sur la lune les trois
dernières apollo 15 16 et 17
il avait la jeep la nouvelle idée de la
nasa le rover vitesse de pointe 10 km
pour la première fois on explore les
environs pour risques de ce pourquoi ils
sont les trous pour témoin à plusieurs
kilomètres même parfois dans les
endroits duquel il ne pouvait plus voir
le lem avec leurs yeux en direct la
dernière mission apollo 17 ans portera
un scientifique harrison schmitt son
travail remarquable dans le choix des
échantillons fera d'apollo 17
l'une des missions les plus riches en
enseignements ce fut aussi plus
convivial
mais en décembre 72 l'odyssée à pour le
se termine trois ans après avoir
décroché la lune les américains
abandonnent le programme apollo
quand retourneront nous sur la lune
selon les prévisions les plus optimistes
ce pourrait être en 2020
et depuis aujourd'hui pour ceux qui
doutent encore de la réalité des
missions apollo il y en a paraît-il
la nasa a mis sur son site internet des
photos inédites où l'on peut voir la
trace du module abandonné à la surface
de la lune
regardez les pointer ici par la flèche
c'est cette petite tache
autant dire que ce n'est probablement
pas ce qui convaincra les sceptiques
quarante ans après certains pensent
encore en effet que les images ont été
tournées dans un studio à hollywood
voilà ça c'est pour la petite histoire
pour la grande maintenant avec un grand
h c'est le propre des grands événements
qui la fabrique tout le monde se
souvient de ce qu'il faisait ce jour-là
on a posé la question à des vacanciers
aujourd'hui à ceux bien sûr qui étaient
en âge de comprendre la portée de ce
premier pas sur la lune où étiez vous le
20 juillet 69 reportage kermené gier
nicolas were au pays du dieu soleil la
lune se fait discrète pour la trouver il
faut longer 40 ans en arrière quand les
souvenirs de jeunesse remontent à la
surface
une petite télévision et cette nuit
magique non
j'écris que l'on demande un joli come
comme mais se sont quittés peut-être que
le monde allait se transforme g a confié
devant mon fils à ce moment là le soir
on a marché sur le doigt là le soir on a
marché sur l'année
tout le monde ne met pas la télé vidéo
mais voilà et je crois qu'on avait
invité des gens qui ne l'avait pas à
participer à l'événement
le petit pas d'armstrong a laissé son
empreinte sur toute une génération
faisant aussi quelques envieux et
quelques sceptiques jëf anciens matin
qui m'a élevé qui m'a dit tu vas quand
même pas croire qu'ils sont montés la
hausse sur la lune avait agité dans le
doute et aujourd'hui non j'y crois même
au pays du dieu soleil la lune compte
encore des fidèles
alors parmi ceux qui ont vécu cet
événement il y avait aussi une petite
fille elle avait 12 ans à l'époque elle
était aussi en vacances dans un camping
avec ses parents et elle est depuis
devenu astronaute c'est claudie haigneré
bonsoir madame haigneré est ce que la
petite fille enceinte que vous étiez
s'est dit ce soir là moi aussi un jour
j'irai dans l'espace en tout cas ce soir
là effectivement dans ce camping au bord
de la mer et une lumière qui s'émiette
un seul est dans mon cerveau et l'ont
mes yeux après avoir vu la lune dans le
ciel et la lune sur le sur l'écran et je
crois qu'elle m'a beaucoup aidé ensuite
à prendre cette décision de m'engager
moi aussi dans l'aventuré spatiale et ça
a déclenché une curiosité une envier
j'ai jamais à gratter demi être engagée
quels souvenirs vous en avez qu'est-ce
qui vous avez marqué précisément ce soir
là vraiment se souvenir de petites
filles c'était une lune très
inaccessibles dans un ciel c'était très
loin et d'avoir l'image sur l'écran
tremblotante du premier pas de l'homme
sur la surface de la lune
donc un peu l'inaccessible devenaient
accessibles rêve se transformer en
réalité
et on a un peu tous envie d'avoir ces
visions puis cette possibilité de se
disent mais pourquoi pas nous et c'est
vrai qu'à un moment donné dans ma vie
j'ai eu la possibilité de dire pourquoi
pas moi et de et de le faire
mais on a on a besoin d'avoir ses
visions de pouvoir se lancer
et ça c'était des images absolument
extraordinaire il y avait toutes les
médias qui ont fait retentir tas dans le
monde entier chacun souvient de
l'endroit où il était c'était pas la
même chose pour le vol de gagarine en 61
où il y avait très peu de moyens de
communication là on avait vraiment
l'image
les images quelques chansons là où c'est
l'image qui a changé vous dites on a
besoin de rêver on parle d'un retour de
l'homme sur la lune en 2020 sur mars à
l'horizon 2050 vous pensez que c'est
important vous pensez que la france doit
participer à cette aventure avec les
américains dans les américains en 2004
ont lancé cette idée de repartir dans
l'exploration habitée l'exploration
automatique avec les sondés de multiples
pays participants et l'europe en
particulier y est très présente
l'exploration habitée c'était trente
années après 72 d'orbites basson j'ai
vécu sur la station millions sur la
station spatiale internationale
et là on relance cette capacité à
dépasser de nouveau les frontières avec
un passage par la lune avant d'envisager
l'exploration martienne est ce que la
lune ou est ce que c'est juste du rêve
est ce qu'on produit et l'humanité a
besoin toujours même dans des conditions
difficiles d'avoir ses capacités à
avancer à regarder devant à se projeter
sur des projets audacieux avoir de de
l'ambition c'est ce qu'il entraînera
aussi à apporter avec la science et de
la technologie du progrès pour notre vie
au quotidien sans projection vers
l'avenir sans essayer de pousser encore
plus loin ses limites que nous avons
aujourd'hui je crois que l'humanité
serait en stagnation j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure d'un impact sur l'humanité de la
première mission lunaire en 1969 je
crois que nous avons aujourd'hui besoin
que notre humanité se mobilisent pour
des objectifs ambitieux c'est la
conquête martienne en passant par une
étape lunaire et l'europe n'y est pas
encore complètement prêtes aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas une vision politique très
fortement dégagé à ce propos moi ce que
je souhaite que je fais aujourd'hui
encore c'est de dire l'europe doit se
mobiliser elle doit être non seulement
invités à participer à l' aventure mais
elle doit être un contributeur actif y
participer avec une contribution pour
que nos jeunes ingénieurs nos jeunes
scientifiques que chacun se sente fière
d'être une partie de l'humanité
conquérante
merci
le dit ignorer pour votre témoignage qui
et pourquoi pas aura peut-être aussi ce
soir animé une petite lumière comme vous
disiez dans la tête d'une de nos jeunes
téléspectatrices par exemple pour clore
ce chapitre sur cet anniversaire on va
maintenant s'intéresser à ceux qui n'ont
pas attendu l'autorisation de la science
pour rêver des écrivains des poètes ont
imaginé le voyage sur la lune bien avant
qu'il ne devienne réalité
avec une capacité visionnaire parfois
étonnantes les plus connus s'appelle
jules verne
edgar poe ou encore rg c'est le dossier
de cette édition il est signé pascal
deschamps et jean marie le quartier je
pense que les poètes ont précédé et les
délais savants et qu'ils ont vu
plusieurs siècles avant ce que les sags
ont finalement été seul capable de
réaliser à l'imagination rien
d'impossible bien sûr mais il fallait
avoir plus que ça pour anticiper les
premiers pas de l'homme sur la lune
il fallait avoir le génie d'un jules
verne la prescience derrière j'ai pour
offrir leurs contemporains des voyages
certes extraordinaire mais plausible
jules verne n'avait-il pas prophétisé
toutes les inventions du xxème siècle ou
presque de ses anticipations
le voyage dans la lune reste à réaliser
si en 1955 ce commentateur a des doutes
imaginez la tête des contemporains du
grand jules camp près d'un siècle plus
tôt il envoie des hommes sur la lune
mais je le faire dès le premier
romancier à utiliser les connaissances
scientifiques de son temps et notamment
des astronomes de l'observatoire de
paris
aujourd'hui encore à la pointe de la
recherche son but était de mettre ses
connaissances à la portée de tous
calculs trajectoire rotation son
rendement fourmille de références
savantes et si la solution proposée par
jules verne un obus tiré par un canon
géant et fantaisiste il avait vu juste
sur bien d'autres points
il a vu juste pour l'endroit d'où le
boulet va décoller puisque pour des
raisons scientifiques le boulet doit
décoller d'une latitude situer entre
zéro et 28 degrés et il va choisir la
floride tout près du fameux cap
canaveral bonne anticipation aussi c'est
le moment le projectile revient sur
terre il va tomber à l'eau exactement
comme la capsule à vau l'eau de la terre
à la lune est adapté au cinéma trente
ans plus tard par méliès mais le
cinéaste magicien va plus loin on
peuplant la lune de créatures hypothèse
que refuser jules verne
soucieux de véracité il a tout inventé
car tout inventé ce n'est parfait tu
pries jules verne était visionnaire il
était beaucoup plus visionner je me suis
certainement modeste hergies car ses
albums
eux aussi sont prémonitoires sa célèbre
fusée à damiers est plus vraie que
nature et c'est le responsable du
programme spatial français qui le dit je
le privilège de pouvoir est sur le pas
de tir quelques heures avant le
lancement et je revois j'ai un flash
dans la tête
la vignette de l'album les tentes qui
arrive le sol lancement de la fusée qui
dit qu au capitaine haddock
regardez capitale où la fusée sa tour
c'est fait
hergé est donc lui aussi partie des
travaux des scientifiques mais il a
réalisé leur rêve avec 15 en avance
oui oui avec tintin avec haddock avec
tournesol on a marché sur la lune on
était avec eux et d'ailleurs rg on verra
au moment de la véritable conquête de la
lune
on verra un très beau dessin amstrong et
aux autres où on voit tintin et ses
compagnons accueillir les astres
d'antisant welcome the moon
mr thompson il fut un temps où la lune
symboliser l'impossible la lune conquise
d'autres rêves d'écrivain et de cinéaste
verront le jour
enfin pas tous j'espère aller pour ce
que les auteurs dont on vient de parler
intéresse le monde daté de demain
propose un cahier spécial nous avons
tous marcher sur la lune avec en prime
deux albums de tintin pour 11 bros 30
il est 20 heures 22 à suivre la nouvelle
tendance et les voleurs le panneau
solaire est semble-t-il en passe de
devenir un objet très prisée en 1 nous
nous rendrons dans un incroyable village
où depuis quelques années les naissances
de jumeaux se multiplient sans raison
apparente
enfin nous serons avec les fous du vélo
qui ont gravi aujourd'hui sous le soleil
la mythique côte du mont ventoux pour le
plaisir uniquement
mais avant cela on va partir au canada
où des incendies impressionnant ravagent
l'ouest du pays des milliers de
personnes de quitter leur domicile
philippe rochot
des milliers de maisons en bois ont
flambé comme des allumettes mais aussi
neuf immeubles détruits par deux foyers
d'incendié c'est toute la montagne qui
est en feu l'équivalent de 300 terrains
de football malgré l'intervention de
huit bombardiers à eau et de cet
hélicoptère impossible d'arrêter les
flammes depuis que je suis là je n'ai
jamais vu de vent aussi fort
c'est très difficile pas de victime mais
plus de 6000 familles ont dû quitter
leur maison
un type a débarqué dans notre jardin en
hurlant il faut sortir d'ici vous devez
effet évacuation difficile car les
autoroutes étaient coupées par les
flammes
tout le monde s'est retrouvé dans les
gymnases ou les écoles pour y passer la
nuit
le vent la chaleur très sèche dans cette
région et quelques imprudences peuvent
expliquer ces incendies spectaculaires
le développement durable attire aussi
les voleurs dont plusieurs pays d'europe
les policiers ont constaté que les
panneaux solaires était devenu une cible
de choix
certains parlent même d'une filière
organisée hakim abdel khaleq frédéric
bohn sur ce hangar une petite fortune
270000 euros de panneaux solaires il y a
un an
des panneaux disparaissent volatilisé en
pleine nuit d'ici là on voit que ça a
été coupée en est membre et après ils
sont montés avec une échelle au long au
long la descente de gouttière on voit
que la gouttière en haut un peu éclaté
ils ont grimpé le long du toit l'eau les
voleurs sont venus une première fois
pour tout simplement démonter les
panneaux avant de revenir l'année
suivante ils ont pris les sept panneaux
duo ans quand l'enfant par la droite ils
ont démonté cette panne ont ils en
avaient préparé 18 au total quatorze
mille euros de préjudice le vol des
panneaux solaires est encore rare en
france mais le phénomène se développe
partout en europe
ici en belgique les malfrats en profiter
de l'échafaudage pour subtiliser les six
panneaux de ce bruxellois
il ya quelques jours j'ai constaté que
nos panneaux solaires qui était sur le
toit ne donnait plus de cours ont donc
j'ai téléphoné la firme
sont venus on est montés sur le toit et
on a constaté que voilà tous les
panneaux solaires et étaient passés ici
en flandre 50 pas nous ont été volés le
propriétaire n'était pas assuré
il a perdu trente mille euros en italie
apparemment c'est un vrai fléau d'après
mon installateurs on aurait déjà volé
sept mille panneaux c'est à dire les
premières filières ont été démantelées
en espagne des trafiquants qui revendait
les panneaux au maroc ou en algérie
9 le prix moyen d'un panneau d'un mètre
carré est de 650 euros
on va s'intéresser maintenant un mystère
depuis une dizaine d'années un village
dans le sud de l'inde constate une
incroyable augmentation des naissances
de jumeaux
le taux est six fois supérieur à la
moyenne mondiale sans que personne ne
puisse avancer la moindre explication
en tout cas pas de manière rationnelle
de nos reportages arnauld miguet
dominique marault tél au milieu de ces
lagunes rizières ses cocotiers se cache
un village très particulier nous sommes
dako dj dans le sud de l'inde au kerala
dans ce quartier regardez il ya des
jumeaux ici dans cette maison également
et dans celle ci les triplés dans
presque toutes les maisons il ya des
humains des triplés mais surtout déchu
moore près de 300 paires du plus jeune
âge à 65 ans
voici donc qu'on ne joue pas et fatima
les doyennes bien entouré chez elle en
fait avant mais ce sont les seuls dans
ce village maintenant il semble que ce
soit devient une règle car dans ce
village de 14000 abl le nombre de
naissances gémellaires depuis une
dizaine d'années et cinq fois et demie
supérieure à la moyenne à l'école
primaire sur la photo de classe lorsque
l'on retire les noms jumeaux voilà ce
que cela donne
22 enfants des visages similaires pas
facile donc pour le corps enseignant de
s'y retrouver dans la salle de classe ce
professeur d'anglais voit souvent double
et cette multiplication de jumeaux aussi
curieux soit elle ne semble pas prête de
s'arrêter
le nombre de jumeaux augmente d'année en
année et même les gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur s'installer au village
commencent eux aussi à avoir des jumeaux
alors ce mystère certains l'expliquent
par la religion dans ce village musulman
à 99%
la légende veut qu'un descendant du
prophète mahomet aux pouvoirs
surnaturels est installée ici la
première mosquée il y as 400 heures
c'est un vrai cadeau du ciel d'avoir
tous ces mails explications divines est
un peu courte et beaucoup de familles
qui se retrouvent avec de bouches à
nourrir plutôt qu'une aimerait bien
comprendre les raisons du phénomène
alors ici chacun va de sa théorie moi je
pense que c'est génétique
cela vient des gènes gene religion ce
médecin n'y crois pas un instant pour
lui les causes sont environnementale
nous pensons qu'il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas dans l'eau je pense qu'il faut
chercher dans cette direction
en attendant que généticien écologistes
et autres anthropologues se penche
sérieusement sur le mystère
les habitants de ce petit village
paisible du kerala savoure temps cette
période de grande jauge justement de
mousson leur nouvelle notoriété de
capital un tiers des jeux c'était repos
aujourd'hui sur le tour de france
repos tout relatif pour certains
l'écrivent du leader du tour alberto
contador a tout de même roulé une heure
et demie de quoi rester en jambes pour
la suite
dans les alpes est pendante et pro se
reposer les amateurs s'amuser si l'on
peut dire comme chaque année depuis
maintenant 17 ans des milliers de
passionnés ont participé au monde de
vélo
au programme pour cette édition la
célèbre côte du mont ventoux
sous le soleil bien sûr le reportage
stéphane despinoy christophe la rocca
telles des fourmis besogneuses il ne
cesse de grimper chaque mètre parcouru
est déjà un exploit
ici tout est un peu irréel le paysage
lunaire et le dénivelé 1600 mètres à
gravir dans les 1 2 derniers kilomètres
mais quasiment une heure de plus que
quand on fait ça grimpe alors nous
allons pouvoir la rai auro la course
attire les à m entraîner mais aussi
d'anciens champions en quête de
sensations une bonne question
8 % de pente parfois plus 11% et en plus
les coureurs sont partis ce matin de
montélimar ilonse en ce sens et le
mettre dans les pédales alors quand les
crampes se déclenche
ça fait très mal sur les bas côtés
on compatit je crois qu'ils vont
défendre au-delà de leurs moyens des
fours mal les connaisseurs savent bien
que le mont ventoux considéré comme une
anomalie géologique est un mythe chez
les coureurs c'est un des plus durs
c'est donc pour le vélo ici disons qu'on
on prend un énorme plaisir pour certains
l'ascension se terminera ici
les champions du tour de france met une
heure pour gravir le ventoux aujourd'hui
les derniers ont mis plus de trois
heures mais tous sont fiers d'avoir
gravi les trois cols c'est les gamins
qui va inscrire je faisais plus trop de
vélo ils ont légale un mois ce tri
l'année dernière pour mes 50 ans ils
m'ont payé sa cadeau empoisonné alors je
dis je m'entraîne givet monsieur
courtois
si l'envié vous gagne le ventoux s'offre
à vous mais vous l'avez compris il se
mérite d'ailleurs je vous recommanderais
pas de le faire avec un vélib à trois
vitesses avant de refermer journal vous
rappelle la principale information
barack obama s'apprête à recevoir dans
les minutes qui viennent les héros de
l'amérique ceux qui ont marché pour la
première fois sur la lune neil armstrong
buzz aldrin et michael collins
cela fera sept nuits 40 ans exactement
pensez-y si vous regardez la lune avant
de refermer et c'est la fin de ce
journal maintenant merci de l'avoir
suivi tout de suite c'est la météo avec
laurent romejko à 20h50 votre série fbi
portés disparus
pour le journal demain à 13 heures vous
avez rendez vous avec ce fils au sein
pour ma part je vous retrouve à 20
heures excellente soirée sur france 2
l'info en continu est aussi sur france 2
point fr
le temps